to all my fellow type A perfectionists
who have obsessed over school work your
body and food this one is for you hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen today we're going to be getting
a little bit personal and talking about
how my perfectionist traits may or may
not have played into a disordered a
quick disclaimer here that I'm not a
psychologist but I did have a chat with
my sister who is a psychologist but I'll
mainly be discussing this from personal
experience and from the research on
disordered eating there are also a lot
of different schools of thought on
chronic dieting and disordered eating
aty and we're just going to be zoning
into a few also if you not already
subscribed get on that today and also
check out my description to download my
free Hunger crushing combo ebook for
some healthy and meal snack ideas super
quick here folks folks I really want to
talk about my sponsor today homog glow
so I have two kids and a dog and yet my
husband says that I'm probably the
messiest out of everyone # ADHD but this
is a conundrum for me because I like
cannot work very well when my space is
feeling disorganized and messy so hom
glow is a five-star cleaning service
with super affordable prices way cheaper
than most services that we've paid for
in the past and also way cheaper than
marital therapy which I would probably
need because because when the house is
approaching dumpster fire territory of
disarray we are gearing up for a massive
blowout but anyway the way it works is
you go to Hom Glow's website to choose
the day and time that you're looking for
and the duration of your cleaning and
you're able to see all the available
cleaners along with their background
checks photos and reviews so if you work
with someone that you really liked in
the past you can rebook that same person
and you can schedule it for that week or
a month from now if you want to rebook
your cleanings on a regular basis bis
you can also sign up for their forever
clean membership which saves you $30 per
hour on future cleanings or unlimited
cleanings for $19 an hour all of which
are backed by their happiness guarantee
and what I love most of all is that 100%
of the cleaning fees and tips go
directly to your cleaner so of course
they're also incentivized to do a great
job yeah I just feel like I can work so
much more efficiently and calmly in my
space when I'm not staring at a bunch of
piles so if you want to stop fighting
with your partner over who made what
mess and just take a huge domestic Duty
off of your plate go to homag glow.com
Abby or scan the QR code on screen to
get your first cleaning for only $9 okay
so let's just kind of start out with a
little story time here my perfectionism
has kind of been
like in short it's given me everything
and taken everything all at the same
time it's made me push and succeed and
and it's made me quit and fail but
honestly if we're to kind of like net
things out it's probably done more harm
than good so here's like a quick little
rundown of how perfectionism has played
out in my life in grade school I danced
competitively and won trophies literally
every time but I would cry myself to
sleep in anxiety about messing
[Music]
up then in high school I traveled to
London and New York working with
producers as professionally trained
singer but eventually my perfectionism
and performance anxiety kind of edged me
out then between high school and
University I transferred my
perfectionistic Tendencies to food
suffering from a very severe case of
orthorexia that very well could have
taken my life in University while in
recovery I drove myself into burnout
fighting for the highest grades in my
class I'll show you how valuable Woods
can be like I cried for days when I got
an A on an assignment instead of an A+
and then as an adult struggling with
infertility and IVF I developed insomnia
and an obsessive relationship with sleep
that literally might have been the
darkest days of my life and here we are
today I'm like 15 years past my academic
career in Ed recovery but the anxious
urges to like overthink and put pressure
on myself to be perfect are obviously
sometimes still there thankfully
motherhood softened me and forced me to
let go of a lot of things as did a ton
of therapy and psychiatric medication so
I'm very grateful that I have access to
all of that but I know that a lot of you
guys are in the thick of it right now I
know you guys can relate You Are My
People I am your people G me Cookie guy
you Cookie so let's talk about this
double-edged sword and how it's likely
affected a lot of our problematic
histories with food well of course we
make a little snack so first of all
perfectionism is a character treat
defined by sky high standards and
critical evaluation for yourself or
others that can be classified into three
main categories self-oriented where the
individual drives themselves into
perfectionism socially prescribed where
you feel that others want you to be
perfect and other oriented where you
expect perfectionism from others now
there's a couple of scales that measure
perfectionism so one is called the frost
multi-dimensional perfectionism scale
and it looks at things like doubts about
actions concerns over parental
expectations High personal standards and
concern for precision and organization
comment below right now if you can
relate to any of that and obviously you
know some level of perfectionism isn't
entirely bad so sometimes it can push us
to stay motivated or do really hard
things or reach super lofty goals I mean
according to my very unscientific media
sources super successful celebrities
like Steve Jobs Lance Armstrong James
Cameron Emma Watson have all claimed to
be perfectionists I mean I've basically
always said that my perfectionism is
great for everyone but not not so great
for me so more often than not
perfectionism becomes maladaptive and
while it's not an official mental
disorder it is heavily correlated with
mental health conditions like insomnia
ocpd depression anxiety ADHD and EDS
we're going to talk a lot more about
that in a hot minute so like a lot of
mental health conditions oh now I have
peanut butter matcha see mistakes can be
delicious H maybe not but like a lot of
mental health conditions basically
perfectionism in young people is on the
rise with one study of over 40,000
college students from 1989 to 2016
showing a significant linear climb
Millennials are apparently thought to be
the generation with the greatest
perfectionistic Tendencies although it's
very possible that gen Zed will very
quickly outdo us once we have more
updated stats and there's a bunch of
potential reasons why this might be
number one let's talk about some of the
major societal and cultural shifts that
Millennials and gen Z's have seen when
compared to our parents and grandparents
so individualism has been steadily On
The Rise since the 1960s which has
likely contributed to us wanting to be
better than our peers and honestly we
kind of have to unlike our parents
generation who could like barely
graduate from high school and be
guaranteed a pretty decent paying job
and Home Ownership by 35 many
Millennials and genes are stuck with
multiple degrees tons of student debt
and little chance of owning anything
possibly in their entire life the result
is that we're basically all burning out
trying to be better stronger faster
harder than our peers and likely it's
fueling our perfectionistic Tendencies I
mean if there are a thousand A+ lwoods
applying to Harvard then you got to
stand out and you're going to need a lot
more than a pink scented resume I think
it gives it a little something extra
don't you think now further perpetuated
by this cultural individualism is how we
are raised so perfectionism actually
does seem to have some potential genetic
factors but it's also highly influenced
by our familial environment this is
particularly evident between mothers and
daughters where one study found that
moms who were perfectionists were
significantly more likely to have
perfectionist daughters but mothers to
daughters aside there's just a lot more
pressure put on kids right now like one
man analysis found that in response to
Rising societal increases in
competitiveness uh individualism
economic inequality and pressure to
excel in school parents have just become
increasingly more demanding and
controlling and the result may be
children who are much more self-critical
and fearful of disappointing their
others themselves or both I don't know
as a parent who is obviously also a
perfectionist this kind of scares
out of me like I don't want this for my
kids and then there's probably one of
the most relevant potential causes of
perfectionism here the role of social
media so social media is kind of like
our generation's co-parent it's where we
go to get advice on literally everything
from contouring tips to weight loss to
how to like fend off an attacker in your
apartment sometimes helpful but also
sometimes not so research suggests that
social media burnout which is a
relatively new psychological phenomenon
is associated with socially prescribed
perfectionism self-oriented negative
perfectionism and metacognitive beliefs
about uncontrollability of thoughts and
dangers and yeah that makes sense like
we got color coordinated feeds curated
photo dumps and highlight reels of
people's lives like when all we're
seeing is perfect perfect perfect
perfect perfect perfect it sets the bar
really high and you know body image
issues are also obviously On The Rise
thanks again things like face tune and
professional ring lights and curated
angles Etc so yeah the expectations for
what we're supposed to look like has
gotten really twisted literally as you
know there are people out there whose
entire job is to sell perfection even if
that takes dangerous diets and a th000
hours in the gym and plastic surgery Etc
and don't get it twisted if you guys
have seen my video on cool sculpting you
know that I'm not anti-plastic surgery
but it needs to be transparently part of
the conversation now obviously if you're
here you know that social media also
drives perfection in our diets I mean
just look at a lot of the wedding a day
videos that I've reviewed we are in an
echo chamber where you know drinking
five low calorie beverages and building
a 20 ingredient power bowl every day is
like presented as the norm if you are
not starting your day with like Corella
sea moss lemon water and ag1 are you
really taking care of your health which
brings me to disordered eating does do
consuming this non-stop Kind of Perfect
diet content on social media cause
eating disorders so one study on over
600 women found that the greater the
Instagram use the higher the likelihood
of orthorexic Tendencies with 49% of the
sample showing symptoms 49% that's a lot
so the question is how does our
perfectionism play a role here could
perfectionism be the missing link to
explain why some people can see a
Creator sharing their 72-hour fast and
can just like whoop scroll on by while
another person could see it and think
yeah I better skip the next few meals
well it's probably not the only Factor
but perfectionism does significantly
increase the risk of developing an
eating disorder the two are very
strongly intertwined and connected with
one study finding higher levels of
perfectionism in anorexia patients
compared to the control group and this
makes sense seeing as people with EDS
tend to hyperfixate on the perfect body
or the perfect weight or the perfect
diet EDS and perfectionism are also both
characterized by extreme rigidity
negative self-talk obsessive thinking
and fear of failure you know Hildy brush
who is a well-known e disorder
psychiatrist once said that patients
with anorexia are every parents and
every teacher's idea of perfection I
don't know about you guys but I
definitely feel seen and speaking of
parents because you probably know where
I'm going with this here seeing as we've
talked so much about alond moms on my
channel and on my platforms but there's
plenty of research linking parental
especially maternal weight concerns and
dieting with negative body image poor
self-esteem disordered eating and
chronic dieting in their kids so when
parents are perfectionists and dieters
and therefore are demonstrating and
celebrating ating and encouraging both
of these Tendencies and behaviors you
can see how this could create a perfect
storm for an ed so if you guys are still
here you are probably a a perfectionist
and B have struggled with your
relationship with food and body or see
you're just like a super fan and for
that I love you the good news is I made
these balls much bigger than I probably
should have hey that's what she said the
other good news is that recovery is
always possible bad news is that it may
be harder for us perfectionists than for
others so research suggests that
perfectionist Ed patients tend to have
significantly less successful treatment
outcomes and yeah that's probably
because you know it's messy
rule-breaking activities feel at odds
with all the little perfect patterns
that keep us feeling calm now if you are
in the act of throws of an Ed and need
medical intervention then of of course
treatment related to Mechanical eating
and symptom Interruption would need to
come first but otherwise working with a
therapy team to address the maladaptive
perfectionism may help to reduce the
chances of
relapse so that was a lot of uncomfy
little truth bombs to process especially
for myself I mean I'm a perfectionist
mom with an ed history I am worried sick
about my own kids but thankfully a huge
part of my journey has to try to really
discern which of these traits and
tendencies serve me and which don't I'm
still in the active process of trying to
unlearn a lot of the maladaptive moments
of my perfectionism myself but I thought
I would share some of the little
strategies on the mindset shifts or
things that I've tried that have worked
for me particularly if you are
struggling with your relationship with
food and you feel that your
perfectionism might be getting in the
way of you finding food Freedom so
number one get help when you can so as
we've discussed perfectionism is a
personality trait it's not a mental
health Disorder so it's not something
that we can necessarily just like
completely cure or abolish but mental
health therapy especially cognitive
behavioral therapy or CBT has shown some
efficacy for managing maladaptive
symptoms now CBT has been a huge part of
my own mental health Journey over the
past 20 plus years and while it is a
painfully slow process I do believe it
absolutely works and if one-on-one
therapy is not an option there's also
some great data on structured support
groups or school-based intervention with
Elementary age children there's also a
lot of great self-help books written by
experts in the field so one of my
favorites that my sister gifted to me
many many years ago is called when
perfect isn't good enough I don't know
it might be worth just like adding that
to your Amazon card now tip number two
is to embrace mistakes mess and Chaos as
I do throwing my myself into chaotic
unstructured imperfect eating was
actually the first step to my Ed
recovery and it definitely worked but
then I basically just shifted my
perfectionistic Tendencies onto
something else which at the time was
school and it wasn't until I had kids
and things got really really chaotic and
messy that I was able to actually let go
and see true flexibility improvements in
all areas of my life as with a lot of
treatments for mental health disorders
like insomnia OCD uh anxiety and E
disorders overcoming a lot of
maladaptive perfectionism for me came
down to exposure so one of the
activities that I do with myself but
also with my kids is like purposefully
making mistakes so I'll color Outside
the Lines or I will send like a rushed
email with typos in it and not give a I
will bake or make selling without a
recipe as I did I mean this ended up way
stickier than it probably should have
but guess what it's going to be all
right the important thing here is to
gather evidence that these small little
errors or mistakes they don't result in
anything catastrophic I still have a job
I still have a family I still have a
roof over my head my kids are healthy
and alive and happy Etc and it's scary
to take those little leaps of Faith
especially for us perfectionists but
challenging those innate fears is a
really really important part of letting
go so tip three is to recognize that
moris not necessarily always better you
know perfectionism can often drive us to
set the goal post higher and higher
which basically leaves us feeling like
we've always failed we're never good
enough we're never going to reach our
goal and this is definitely an area
where perfectionism and eating disorders
intersect it definitely was for me so
what started out as me making some
moderate diet changes like ordering
salad with my burger instead of fries
quickly evolve to me cutting out all
sugar all fats and all carbs same with
folks with restrictive EDS like anorexia
it might start off as a quest to lose a
few pounds but the goal post quickly
becomes overtaken by this assumption
that if some is good more is better
until obviously it's not now one thing
that's been helpful for me is to write
down all the little tiny goals in my day
even the seemingly menial tasks so that
I can kind of like stay in the now and
then each time I check one of them off I
get this little sense of satisfaction
and a hit of dopamine so I don't have
that drive and need to push it harder or
faster or further and then ultimately
burn out or take it to a dangerous
extreme seeing those little mini
successes is also a good reminder to
myself when I'm being hypercritical that
I have done a lot of great things which
really helps to downplay the voice
telling me that it's not enough hold
that thought I got to wash my hands this
is as long as I can tolerate this and
tip four and probably the most important
for a lot of you guys who are watching
is to take take a social media break if
you struggle with social comparison I
want you to take this one thing away
today social media is not real life it's
heavily cured to help the Creator
position themselves as in some way
Superior to you healthier diet hotter
body higher level knowledge though I
would say I've seen a lot of creators
where I would question that one but
anyways yeah even though I don't
personally feel triggered by a lot of
other people's bodies online I know that
social media is not good for my mental
health mainly because my type A
tendencies in this season of my life are
largely related to my role as a mom and
I think I've said this before in other
videos but I've watched a lot of wedding
a day videos and sometimes I'm like holy
am I the only one that's not making
these elaborate healthy meals from
scratch every single day for my kids
three times a day and this is a work in
progress obviously but I've actively
chosen to try to be more kind to myself
and like I said like celebrate the
little wins like my kids don't think I'm
any less of a mom because we eat
rotisserie chicken instead of me like
schlepping out my Ina Garden book I know
I'm an amazing mom I know I'm a great
wife and what I lack in domestic
cleaning skills I make up for with some
food that my family will sometimes at
least eat that's a win right so yeah
sometimes you just got to look at
yourself in the mirror and say you
do a good job I mean that's what I do
anyway but on that note I hope this was
helpful for those of you who are
struggling with perfectionism and your
relationship with food if you have any
advice to share please leave it in the
comments I'm sure all of us can learn
from one another and that's all that I
have for you guys today if you liked it
be sure to give it a thumbs up and don't
forget to get your hands on my Hunger
crushing combo ebook and I'll see you
next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
yeah